taking a gravity-defying catch or
patrick peterson intercepting the ball
for a game-winning touchdown playmakers
dominate the passing game on both sides
of the ball so we focused on three key
positions quarterbacks receivers and
defenders in coverage let's start with
quarterback new body relative throws
give you a chance to lead your tall
receivers high above a defenders reach
or throw low on a curl route to wall off
the defender protecting both the ball
and your receiver as an example if
Russell Wilson would have used a body
relative low throw to end the Super Bowl
we'd probably be referring to the
Seahawks of the two-time defending champ
now edges in the NFL never cease to
amaze me that one of the most exciting
and dynamic plays in any sport as a
receiver you can now choose from one of
three new catch types to beat the
competition and keep your drive alive
first a possession catch will increase
your chance of a completion to get that
critical first down but might sacrifice
yards next a rack or run after catch
adjust your out so you can attempt to
gain extra yards after the catch and
finally use an aggressive catch to
attack the ball at its highest point and
I know what you're thinking now the game
is all about offense but don't worry we
didn't forget about defense at the
defender in coverage going for the
interception or SWAT can be risky for
the first time now you'll have the
ability to play the receiver instead of
just the ball you can make it an attempt
to the tackle or use the new play
receiver mechanic to execute a
well-timed hit dislodging the ball and
preventing the catch madden NFL 16 is
delivering tools so you can be the
playmaker on the field at the
quarterback receiver and defender and
coverage and with draft champions you'll
start your playmaker journey off the
field in this exciting new fantasy
inspired mode you'll have your first
shot to prove you the playmaker both on
and off the field right here at e3 or
for those of you at home when the game
launches on August 25th